all right wayne
yes wayne where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from sweden
louisiana
shreveport and uh tell me about your
family growing up um
my family i had my mother and my father
in my life
my childhood was was was good
up until
a certain point
i remember
being a happy uh
go lucky child
um
my mother used to drink but i didn't
know anything about um
drinking anything like that i just know
that my mother used to drink and she
would come home
and
she would always fall asleep
and so i'm the oldest of three children
um it's me my baby brother and my baby
sister
so um at an early age
uh
i had to look out for my brothers and my
brother and my sister
um
and my mother would come home and
go
farm sleep sometimes she would come home
and make dinner for us and stuff like
that but
most of the time she would come home and
go to sleep and by me being from
sweetboy louisiana i was raised in a
little town called cullen louisiana it's
like maybe 50 to 60 miles outside of
shreveport
and um i had a lot of family out there
and we were all in the same vicinity so
it was nothing for me my sister my
brother to go to my auntie's house and
eat and stuff like that and um
you know um
it was my childhood was
it was up
it was it got confusing at times because
my father i really
uh didn't get to spend a lot of time
with him because i used to always wonder
why uh he wasn't around a lot
um
and so later on growing up i found out
that my father had
four different sets of kids he had a lot
of women in a little small town that i
was raised in
um but when he came by he was you know
as far as i can remember
in the beginning he was he was kind
uh he was loving
um
and uh
he he was a strong figure in my life
and um
i used to go to his house
and visit him when he was he was living
with another lady
and and the other lady didn't like me
and i didn't understand why
and so
um
my father
would come to our house sometime and
be with my mom and they would argue and
and fight and stuff like that sometime
and
i didn't know what was going on so i
remember one day
i think i was maybe four
he came over and he started
beating up my mother
and i remember i tried to stop him from
beating on my mother
and he slapped me in my mouth and
knocked two of my teeth out
and
i didn't know if
he did that because he didn't love me
or if i was being
um
out of line or i didn't know cause like
i said i was four years old
and um one day
he came over my mother was drinking
sleep as usual and he was drinking he
had been drinking too
and he told me to come and sit on his
lap
and so i did you know this is my father
you know i
i don't know any other man but him and i
you know
i'm a child so
i don't think he's going to harm me or
hurt me anything like that
and so um
he started to rub on my legs and stuff
like that and at first it started off
like uh like playing
you know um
playing around with me and stuff like
that
uh i never thought anything of it so
that's how it started
and then it started to progress so my
childhood
i'm still trying to figure out um
the reason why
he's not around a lot because i i can't
comprehend
that he
he has other another family with another
woman i'm just under an impression that
he's staying somewhere else um
and my mother she never
uh
told us anything about
the reason why
things were the way they were um
and so i remember one distinct day
i came home from around at my auntie's
house and i came home and my father was
there when my mother and i had been
drinking
and
um so
i don't know what i did i don't know if
i did anything or not but he
told me to pull by my pants and he's
like he was gonna whip me
you know um
i don't know
to this day when i think about it if i
did anything wrong
or anything like that but
he did exactly like he didn't whoop me
um
he he he stuck his finger in my rectum
um
i don't
i don't know why he did it i just
remember the pain
and he told me not to tell nobody
because what he was doing was nothing
wrong he was doing it because he loved
me
i don't know
um i didn't know what to believe i'm
only four i didn't know what to believe
so i i never said anything to anybody
about it
but
i believe that's when i changed
um
i started to be really really
mean and
and and fighting towards my little
brother and my little sister
um i started looking at my mom in in a
different way
um
because i thought that she should know
any and everything that's going on in my
life i'm only four years old i don't
have no choice but to try to understand
what i just try to understand what i did
wrong
you know and my father he was he would
he was somewhere he only he did it the
one time
but he would come around and he would
give me money and he would always ask me
you didn't tell nobody did you you
didn't tell nobody about the game we
played i was like no i didn't tell
nobody but i didn't respond to him like
i used to i didn't go
and and and i wasn't happy to see him
like i usually was um
i remember one day
my mother told me to do something
and i i um
i didn't do it because i didn't want to
listen to her anymore
because i didn't trust her
um
so she spent she whipped me
and after she woke me
um i waited until she went to sleep
and i set the house on fire with her in
it
and i ran around to monty's house and i
sat on the porch and i watched our house
burn
thank god
that my mother woke up and
and she came she got out of the house my
brother and sister were already in my
auntie's house
and my mother asked me why i did it
and i just didn't say nothing
i just didn't say anything
i started to
beat on my brother beat on my little
sister
uh i remember hitting my cousin in here
busting his head
uh
i was just out of control because i was
in pain and i didn't understand why
i was in pain because i still didn't
understand why what happened to me
happened to me
so
moving forward a little bit
my mother
she wasn't married to my father
she married my stepfather
and he uh
he lived out here in california
so he brought me my baby sister my baby
brother my mom to california
um
and
i used to ask my mother all the time
because once we got out here
being from the country and then moving
to the city
the speed changed
things started to happen too fast for me
and it was hard for me to catch up with
what was going on
so
i kind of shut down
and a lot of things i didn't want to do
i came i became very rebellious
um
i started doing a lot of things that i
didn't want to do because i started
doing things to hurt my mother
i didn't want to listen to her anymore i
didn't want to i don't want her telling
me nothing
uh
you know because i'm still trying to
find figure out why didn't you let this
happen to me why did you let this pain
and and
[Music]
and disrespect
you know happened to me i kind of
understand more about it now that i'm
older but then at that at that age i
didn't so i just acted out i didn't know
how to talk to anybody i didn't know how
to explain
to anybody what was going on with me i
didn't know how to explain to anybody
that i had been hurt
um because i i didn't i'm four years i
didn't understand anything so we came
out here i was five
uh my mother put put us in school
and i like school
uh i would go to school and
that's where i could be a kid
you know because i didn't have to look
after my brother and my sister when i
was in school i could be a kid i could
run around i could play
i could get to know people and and and
hang out with other kids
um
and then when i came home
i had to uh look out for my big brother
and sister then i had to do my homework
i had to make sure they they did their
homework so my childhood became limited
so the rebellion
just started to grow and grow and grow i
started to not do what my mother wanted
me to do
i started to
wanting to do what i wanted to do and
what i wanted to do was anything i could
to hurt her
because i didn't know how to talk to her
so my mother
used to whoop me and whoop me in with me
and
it got to the point where the weapons
just didn't they just didn't hurt
anymore
um i started i began to talk back
i began to be very disrespectful
um i just began to be
everything
that i that i should have been i was i
was the opposite of that
and
you know
i'm gonna speed it up a little bit um as
i got older
that same rebellion took me to a whole
different place in my life
um i started hanging out with the wrong
crowd
i started just uh smoke weed
you know um i was supposed i think i was
probably about excuse me 10
10 or 11. i think i was in 11 because i
think i was in the i was getting ready
to graduate from elementary school i
think i was in sixth grade when i first
started smoking weed
um
and i liked it
um because it took me
out of a place of pain
and to put me into
another um
how can i say it took me to another
place of
of um
i guess
fun um
i was able to open up
more
um
to my friends to a certain extent
about
what i had been through but i would
never give up the core
the core root
of my problem
so
i started to
lose interest
in being a good kid
and started to be attracted to being a
rebellious kid
i didn't know how to talk to girls you
know and
the the marijuana gave me
um
a newfound sense of
um how can i say um
of who i was i was able to
to open up and
and and and and talk to girls and stuff
like that but little did i know
the resentment i held against my mom i
took out on on other females i mean i've
had the god has blessed me with a lot of
beautiful females a lot of wholesome
females a lot of females who love me
and one of the best me and and had went
to bat for me
but
the rebellion i had against my mother
and the anger i held against my mom
wouldn't let me get that love back
uh wouldn't let me give that um
that decency back wouldn't let me give
that caring and sharing uh that they
were showing me would let me give it
back because i thought that
by me doing what i was doing and hurting
other females i looked at it as hurting
my mom
you know but my mother loved me
unconditionally to this day i've never
told my mom my mom has been gone almost
30 years
i've never told her that
um
and by not opening up and and trying to
explain to her
what happened to me after i got older
is because i don't know i
i guess
the place where i was raised like i'm
i'm a 59 baby and i was raised in the
early 60s
and 70s and um i was taught and
understood that a man was never supposed
to cry
a man was never supposed to show a sign
of weakness
and by me
opening up and wanting to tell my mom
wanting to do the right thing
which saw a sign of weakness
so i stopped caring about
my well-being and i started putting my
friends and
everything else before my well-being and
i started caring about what other people
thought about me instead of caring about
what my mom thought about me
and like i said it led me down a dark
road and i got deeper and deeper into
drug addiction
uh
the deeper i got the more lost i became
and it was a struggle it's been a
struggle all the way up to this point
and i'm 62 years old
it's been a struggle i've been in and
out of drug programs
um i go to the programs for all the
right reasons
but i leave for all the wrong reasons i
became selfish
uh
closed-minded
you know
and where i lived it was a lot of gang
activity
it it the gang activity in those days is
not like the gang activity of these days
where they do all this shooting and
stuff like that
it was more bullying
and uh forcing you
into joining gangs
and i remember
one day my mother told me she said if
you ever join a gang or if i ever catch
you with a tattoo on you
i'm gonna kill you
and something about the way she said
that to me
made me believe she was going to do
exactly what she said
um so i became in that aspect more
afraid of my mom than i did of the gang
members
they were constantly chasing me home
from school
you know trying to get me to join these
gangs and i had
one gang
at school on this side of town
chasing me home then i
live right across the street from the
projects and these guys are trying to
get me to join so i was stuck between a
rock and a hard place so i had to come i
had to become very very manipulative
you know in order to survive in the
surroundings that i was in i had to act
a certain way
around certain people
to get certain results
so i wouldn't get beat up uh i wouldn't
get uh uh
robbed or
you know they wouldn't beat up my baby
brother my baby sister because everybody
knew everybody
um and life was extremely extremely hard
because it really really i really lost
myself because
the lie i was living
started to become my truth
um
and until this day i've never told
anybody that
i've never told anybody this
but you know i'm in recovery now i have
47 days clean
i'm in recovery i have a sponsor
and my sponsor is taking me through the
work of the big books of alcoholics
anonymous and it tells me that i have to
i have to let go of all that pain
i have to let go of all that sorrow and
i have to start forgiving people
i'm early in the work
but i go to a lot of meetings and stuff
like that and they kind of clarify
and and hit on different points
in their lives that
happened in mine
um
i'm still afraid
um
to look
forward because
i've never looked past my nose at my
future
but
god has blessed me to continue to have
good people in my life i have a i have a
god has blessed me with a
a beautiful female
uh she's been with me for 17 years and
i've took this young lady through the
ringer
but for some reason she refuses to give
up on me
um
so she's giving me hope um
i'm starting to get to the point to
where
that's why when i when somebody
approached me about this interview i
kind of um
i kind of hesitated
because i didn't know
how you were going to look at me
i don't know how the people who are
watching this interview is gonna look at
me
but
i know
that it's not about
what you guys think about me it's about
me being free
um and this is what i have to do to be
free and i'm gonna have to do it anyway
going through the work with my sponsor
so i have to start somewhere
you know um you know i think sometimes
why did i wait so long
to finally get it to finally want
to be the person that i know i wanted to
be you know i didn't graduate from
school i didn't get to go to college
you know
i went to the school of hard knocks the
streets was my school um
and everything that uh associated with
the streets i mean
you know my drug addiction i did some
things boy that i wouldn't i didn't want
to tell anybody i did
i've
almost slept with another man i've i've
let another man have all sex with me
um
i've almost let another man have
intercourse with me
you know um
i'm just so grateful and thankful
that god intervened when he did
you know um
the incident with the guy that wanted to
have intercourse with me
i think the only reason why that didn't
happen is because of the drugs we were
smoking and he couldn't he couldn't get
erection
uh
it's embarrassing
to tell this story yes it is
but it's necessary
um for my future it's necessary
for me to maintain my sanity it's
necessary for me to grow
um
by getting rid of my hurts and my pains
and my and my sorrows and my
embarrassment
um
because if i don't it's going to
continue to stump my growth
in my life and
you know like i said i'm 62 years old i
don't think i have a whole lot of time
left
so i have to start somewhere you know
and as a
result of all the drugs and all that
stuff i'm starting to lose
my teeth they're coming out slowly but
surely
um
is that embarrassing to me yes
uh
is it necessary to me no
but i can't tell nature how to be nature
all i can do is try to put myself in a
position to where
um when these things arise i can kind of
make a way
to um
take care of it like now you know i've
been clean for 47 days i make my
doctor's appointments i go to the
dentist work start getting ready to
start the process of making me some
partials
you know and
for some reason
i can't i've always loved to smile
even with with my teeth out i still
smile
you know and i do it unconsciously
because that's just who i am
um i've never been a bad kid i've never
been a bad guy i just made bad decisions
uh for all the wrong reasons
so um
i'm just at the point in the stage of my
life now to where i'm taking
responsibility
um
and owning up
you know to um the results that happened
in my life because nobody put a gun to
my head nobody put a knife around my
throat nobody did anything of that
nature to make me do what i did or make
me choose the path of my life that i
chose it was all
because of
i was supposed to feel and how i wanted
you to feel
uh about me i didn't care
if you didn't know how i feel about you
because you didn't care to me you didn't
matter to me it was all about me and it
was all about what you could do for me
if you couldn't do anything for me me i
didn't have no time for you
and that's how i went through all these
different relationships with all these
different females i didn't care about
what you did for me because i didn't
appreciate what you did for me because i
didn't appreciate myself
so i lived uh i lived uh
a double life
um
i'm so grateful and thankful you mark
for
allowing me to come
you know and and open up and [ __ ] and i
know this is going to be
seen by a lot of people but i don't care
i don't care because i'm free
um
and it's a start in the right direction
you know and as i'm speaking as i'm
telling you this i'm
i'm starting to feel better about a
whole lot of things
um it's like a weight has been lifted
off my shoulders because i always told
myself i'm gonna take that to the grave
ain't nobody gonna never know that about
me
ain't nobody gonna never know the almost
embarrassing and
and and and
things that i've done and you know i'm
just glad that it was some reliance on
the cross i mean i i've have raw people
and stuff like that in my drug addiction
but as far as hurting anybody or
killing anybody or maiming anybody i
wasn't that guy
um
if i could manipulate you
out of what i wanted if i could
manipulate you into doing what i wanted
um that i was that guy
you know and
i didn't waste a lot of time with it if
you didn't do what i wanted you to do
that means that i wasn't doing what i
was supposed to do so
to me that made you stronger than me
so i would move on to the next person
you know but i'm just thankful and
grateful that god brought me to the
place that i am right now
you know and i know a whole lot more
than i did
before i got here and if my mother was
still alive i would love to just
probably just hug her and tell her momma
i'm sorry
because she did the best she could do
what she had
she wanted the best for me she showed it
on a continual basis
she never gave up on me she tried to
talk to me she took me to psychiatrists
and the psychiatrist would tell my
mother was nothing wrong with me and my
mother would tell the psychiatrist y'all
crazy because something's wrong with my
son he's crazy
if i could do anything if i could do
anything right now i just wouldn't tell
my mother i'm sorry
and i left i thank the favorite things
you've done for me and even when my
mother died
my auntie told me asked me to tell my
mother asked my mother for forgiveness
and she was on a deathbed and and i told
her i said mama if you forgive me i'm
sorry if you forgive me squeeze my hand
and my mother squirts my hand and she
died
she died
i'm sorry
it's been hard
it's been hard because
i really never had anybody to talk to
about it because
i would always
i would always uh wonder what you would
think about me because
i didn't
i didn't want to look weak
i didn't want to show
i didn't want to show no humility
you know but i'm human
i'm human and it hurts to not be who you
want to be
but you can't be who you want to be
because you're so used to being who you
don't want to be
it is hard to come back
it's hard to come back to that space
where everything in your life was fine
where everything in your life mattered
uh but i'm trying
i'm trying and god is blessing me that's
why i'm still here
it takes courage to do what you're doing
it takes more than courage man it takes
a lot of belief
i have to believe in myself when nobody
else will believe in me i have to
believe that i can change
i have to believe that i can get back to
that place of my life where i matter
i have to believe that on a daily basis
and this last program that i've been
i've took myself to the program
i'm tired of living like this
i would always i was the type of addict
somewhere
i would get clean for a minute and
and i would accumulate things i would
get the girl
i would get the clothes
the joelles and all that and the
prestige and and i would have people
trust me
knowing that i was gonna let all them
down because i just wanted what i wanted
because the more things i accumulated
the more i got you to trust me the more
i got you to believe in me when i went
and did what i want to do i could get
more out of you i would have more things
at the pond
i found my wedding i've been married i
found my wedding ring i found my baby
sister's radio i used to steal out of my
mother's purse i i was i was just
i was addicted to all the wrong things
can you tell me what uh stopping crack
yes it's like
it's hard
i was staying outside
before i came in here and i had to pray
from the time i got here until i walked
into this door i had to pray because
everything
that's out there attracts me
i used to be here
i used to be these people
and everything about it still attracts
me but i have to fight
i have to fight every day i have to pray
i have to believe
that i can do that i have to believe
that i can change i have to believe that
i can allow
god to continue to bless me and to bring
me back to who i am
did you want to live on skid row yes you
did right yes i'm being on skid row i
used to walk up and down the streets
with the buggies
and and eat out of trash cans
i've done all that
it was down here
where i lit a man
i have all sex with me
it was right here on skid row right here
on seventh and uh
um i can't think of you snap seventh to
stanford
um
yeah for ten dollar rock
for ten dollar rock
you know it's i i believe more there's
so much stuff
bundled deep down inside of me that
wants to come out
and i find i finally became willing
i finally became willing to accept the
fact
that
everything i did
was experience
um
i have to understand that
i had to experience the bad to
appreciate the good
you know so i have to have to talk about
the bad things in my life to open up and
make room for the good things in my life
you know and i have to continue to
believe on a daily basis that the things
i went through
wasn't me
i'm at the point now where i called it
the other guy
you know all the bad things that
happened in my life it didn't happen to
me it happened to the other guy
because of god and i am now
um
he doesn't even come close to the other
guy
you know it's it's like
getting up and riding a bike again it's
going to take a lot of time and a lot of
effort and a lot of um
concentration and a lot of willingness
but i can do it
i can do it you know and i've tried to
get clean a lot of times but i've never
been this serious in my life
you know um
i don't think about getting high
even when i was out there
the addiction works in different ways it
was trying to bring back memories
of the good times
when i was on skid row
but the reality of my experience tells
me that
ain't gonna be nothing good
once the party is over
what do you think has changed in you
that you're now ready to do it my belief
my belief has changed
uh
my willingness has
become more stronger because i know
right from wrong mark
i'm not a dumb guy by any aspect i'm
very very intelligent
but i spent all that energy and
intelligence on learning street
knowledge
and not book knowledge i learned just
enough book knowledge to get me by
um
i love reading um
i like to write
um
i like to tell stories
because telling stories telling people
stories i can make up stuff
and make other people believe that the
story i'm telling is about somebody else
but the story i'm telling is really
about me
um
i feel
i feel like a great way has been lifted
off my shoulder because i know deep down
in my heart that it's the right thing to
do
you know um i'm not embarrassed about
anybody seeing this i'm not embarrassed
about
letting anybody know my story
um
if it can help anybody
god bless them
um i think the message i'm trying to
relay is that don't be don't be don't be
afraid of your experience
don't be afraid of the things you go
through because if you're here today
and you have an opportunity to change an
opportunity to understand
uh that you need to change
um
please don't hesitate to do it
because i sell myself all the time me
being 62 is better late than never
you know i don't know what tomorrow
brings
i don't know what 15 minutes from now
holds but i know i won't be high
you know um that's all the power i have
um and i just have to keep on moving on
man i just have to keep on being strong
i have to keep on believing in myself i
don't have to i don't i can't afford to
have
uh to try to spend all my time and
energy trying to have someone else
believe in me
believing in myself will allow me to be
who i am and not who i think you want me
to be that was a big misconception in my
life too
i tried to be what everybody else wanted
me to be
to get out of being me because
i was in so much pain and confusion
and
you know when i think about it now mark
you know i had to
i have to i have to pray for my father
i have to pray for my father and ask for
his forgiveness because that's what the
program
wants me to do that's what that's what
the program teaches me to do
i can't hold anybody else accountable
for my mistakes my choices
um
people are sick
sick people do sick things
um
and all i can do
if i want to continue to grow is forgive
them
for being sick forgive them for doing
the things they did
you know i know my mother loves me
she proved it to me when she sweats my
hand on her dying bed she forgave me
you know and i know she's looking down
on me right now at this interview
you know and and
i'm happy with that
i'm happy with that
and the change in me is real
the change in me is real
you know i'm gonna say this and shut up
um
to anybody who's listening
you can say
you're changing all you want to but if
what you're saying is not what you're
living
you're doing yourself a disservice
you know stop living in the fantasy
world get back to the real world
um own up to your wrongs own up to your
um
to your experiences because the same
experiences that kept you down
can open the door for new experiences to
bring you up
it's great to see somebody actually
doing it thank you
yeah it's hard man but it's doable
it's doable you know when you remove you
out of your own way
you'll be you'll be surprised the things
that you can do like i like even i've
been 47 days clean i got money in my
pocket
i can go buy me a hamburger if i'm
hungry i can buy me a soda or water if
i'm thirsty i got cigarettes
you know uh i can do basically what i
want to do
you know and
that's what living is
being able to feed yourself close
yourself do things to make you feel good
that's what i do i do things that make
me feel good even if like riding the
train i'm from the little valley and
riding train to get here
i was content
even though i knew
that i was going to have to get real
it was an opportunity for me to better
to better myself i didn't look at it as
well what are people going to think
about me
is any of my family members going to see
this
i don't give a [ __ ]
straight up
you know because i don't want you to
like me for who you want me to be i want
you to like me for who i am
you know be open with me and i'll be
open with you no longer do what you
think about me matter
you know because what you eat don't make
me [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and i don't
mean to be disrespectful when i say that
but it's the truth
if you drink a beer it's not going to
get me drunk
so why should i let what you think about
me [ __ ] my life up
been there done that
i forgive everybody involved
but i got to forgive myself more than
anything
because i'm the one that matters
you know once i get myself together i
can start to do what i need to do to
help others get their stuff together you
know and i hope that's what someone gets
out of this interview
beautiful talk thank you thank you thank
you
you